hello and welcome to this unusual ai
coffee break today we'll share with you
some of our own work which was accepted
at acl 2022
i know what you could think it might not
seem like much especially when we
compare our work with papers that we
have previously covered on a channel
coming from big companies and many
authors but you know we are proud of our
paper it is honest work
we'll be presenting this at acl 2022 in
the last week of may so in case you will
be attending the acl conference too i
guess we'll see you in dublin
don't hesitate to say hi if you're
around
otherwise you can have a look at what we
have been working on recently in this
video enjoy
hello we are happy to present our work
on vows a task independent benchmark
meant for testing vision and language
models with specific linguistic
phenomena
why did we do the trouble in setting up
this benchmark
well during the last years we have seen
an explosion of transformer-based vision
and language models pre-trained on large
amounts of image taxpayers
each one of these models pushes
state-of-the-art on vision and language
tasks such as visual question answering
visual common sense reasoning image
retrieval phrase grounding
so we got a message the accuracies on
these task specific benchmarks are
increasing steadily
but do we know what the models have
actually learned
what is it that a vision and language
transformer understood when assigning a
high score for this image and this
sentence to match
and the low score for this one
do vision and language models focus on
the right thing or do they focus on
biases as shown by previous work
to shed more light on this aspect we
propose a more task agnostic direction
and introduce vowels that test the
sensitivity of vision and language
models to specific linguistic phenomena
that affect both the linguistic and the
visual modalities
we target existence plurality counting
spatial relations actions and entity
correference
but how do we test whether the vision
and language models have captured this
phenomena
by foiling a method previously applied
for vision and language models only for
noun phrases by ravi shekhar and
collaborators and on counting by us in
previous work
foiling basically means that we take the
caption of an image and produce a foil
by altering the caption
such that it does not describe the image
anymore
and we do these phrase alterations by
focusing on six specific pieces such as
existence plurality counting spatial
relations actions and entity
correference where each piece can
consist of one or more instruments in
case we found more than one interesting
way to create foil instances
for example in the case of the actions
piece we have two instruments one in
which the action verb is changed with a
different action and one in which actins
are swapped
counting and correference also are
pieces that have more than one
instrument and we create these foils by
making sure that they fail to describe
the image that they are grammatical and
otherwise valid sentences
this is not easy to do because avoid
caption may be less likely than the
original caption
for example though it's not impossible
it is statistically less likely for
plants to cut a man than a man to cut
plants and large vision and language
models could pick up on this
therefore to obtain valid foils we must
take action
first we make use of strong language
models to propose foils
second we use natural language inference
or short nli
to filter out foils that could be still
describing the image since when
constructing foils we need to ensure
that they fail to describe the image
to test this automatically we apply
natural language inference with the
following rationale we consider an image
to be the premise and its caption its
entailed hypothesis
in addition we consider the caption to
be the premise and the foil is its
hypothesis
if an nli model predicts the foil to
contradict or to be neutral with respect
to the caption
we take this as an indicator of a valid
foil
if an nli predicts the foil to be
entailed by the caption it cannot be a
good foil since by transitivity it will
give a truthful description of the image
and we filter these foils out but this
procedure is not perfect it is just an
indicator for valid foils therefore as a
third measure for generating valid foils
we employ human annotators to validate
the data used in valves
so after filtering and human evaluation
we have as many test instances as
described in this table
note that valves does not deliver any
training data but only test data
since it is a zero-shot testing
benchmark only it is designed to
leverage the existing capabilities of
vision and language models after
pre-training
fine-tuning would only enable models to
exploit artifacts or statistical biases
in the data and we all know that these
models like to cheat and take shortcuts
and as we said we are interested in
assessing what capabilities the vision
and language models have after
pre-training
we experiment with five vision and
language models on valves namely with
clip alex mert wilbert wilber12 1 and
visual bird
two of our most important evaluation
metrics are the accuracy of the models
in classifying image sentence pairs into
captions and foils
perhaps more relevant for this video we
will showcase our more permissive metric
the pairwise accuracy which measures
whether the image sentence alignment
score is greater for the correct image
text pair
than for its foiled pair for more
metrics and results on them do check out
our paper the results with pairwise
accuracy are shown here and they are
consistent with the results we got from
the other metrics is that the best zero
shot performance is achieved by wilbur
12 in one followed by wilbert lxmert
clip and finally visual bird
it's notable how instruments centered on
individual objects like existence and
noun phrases are almost solved by
wilbert 12 1 highlighting that models
are capable of identifying named objects
in their presence in images
however none of the remaining pieces can
be reliably solved in our adversarial
foiling settings we see from the
plurality and counting instruments that
vision and language models have trouble
distinguishing references to single
versus multiple objects or counting them
in an image the relation piece shows
that they have difficulties in correctly
classifying a named spatial relation
between objects in an image they also
have trouble distinguishing actions and
identifying their participants even if
supported by plausibility biases as we
see in the actions piece
from the correference piece we find out
that tracing multiple references to the
same object in an image by using
pronouns is also difficult for vision
and language models as a sanity check
and because it's an interesting
experiment we also benchmark two
text-only models gpt-1 in gpt2 to assess
whether vols is solvable by these
unimodal models by computing the
perplexity of the correct and the foiled
caption no image here and predicting the
entry with the lowest perplexity if the
perplexity is higher for the foil we
take this as an indication that the
foiled caption may suffer from
plausibility bias or other linguistic
biases
and it's interesting to see that in some
cases the text only gpt models have
captured the plausibility of the world
better than the vision and language
models
so to sum up
vals is a benchmark that uses the lens
of linguistic constructs to help the
community improve vision and language
models by hard testing their visual
grounding capabilities
our experiments show that vision and
language models identify named objects
in their presence in images well as
shown by the existence piece but
struggle to ground their interdependence
and relationships in visual scenes when
forced to respect linguistic indicators
we would really like to encourage the
community to use vowels for measuring
progress towards language grounding with
vision and language models and even more
valves could be used as an indirect
assessment of data sets as models could
be evaluated before and after training
or fine-tuning to see whether a data set
helps models improve on any of the
aspects tested by valves
if you're interested do check out the
walls data on github and if you have any
questions do not hesitate to contact us
[Music]
[Music]
you